-So, I want to ask
about the book.
-Yeah.
-So what made you decide --
Obviously, you're a "New York
Times" best-selling author.
You've never written
a kids book before.
What brought along
the idea to write this?
-I think, for me,
I thought I sort of
missed my window
to have children.
I just -- I was busy at work,
and then some other things
happened in life, and sometimes
you think you missed that.
And deep inside,
I kind of wished and hoped
and sort of prayed for it.
And I would scribble
in my journal.
You know, 'cause I felt like
maybe it would happen,
and I felt like I loved her
before I held her.
Like, I felt like the idea of
her, like, melted me, kind of.
And so that's
where the title came from.
-And have you read it
to her yet?
-I did.
-And how was -- Did she like it?
-Well, her go-to
is "Good Night Moon,"
so I had to wrestle
that one out of her hand.
But when I got this one in,
I was flipping through it,
and her eyes
were kind of traveling,
like from page to page,
so I was digging that.
-I will say, like, this is --
it's a lot --
It has a lot in it that I feel
like my son would dig, too.
-You think?
-'Cause he likes animals.
He likes to point at things
and see them.
-Yes. Yeah. She was chomping
on the elephant page.
-Also, I would love
to get "Good Night Moon"
out of his hands, too.
-How are they so hooked on that?
-It's weird.
-What is it?
-It's weirdly hypnotic
and strange,
and I hate it so much.
[ Laughter ]
There's so many things about it
that I hate so much.
And, also,
it takes a minute to read it.
-It's over.
-And when it starts, I'm like,
"Oh, here we go!"
"Oh, let me guess --
mittens and kittens.
Oh, great."
But I'm so bummed out,
and I don't know why
I can't just be an adult
and be like, "Just read."
-Right.
-"It's less than 100 words."
And I'm so upset reading it,
so I can't.
I'm looking forward
to reading this.
And then, tell me about,
you got Kelly Clarkson --
-[ Gasps ]
-You played it for me backstage.
Stunning.
How did you get Kelly Clarkson
to sing the lyrics to your book
that were words.
They weren't even lyrics.
-You know what?
I asked her if she would do it.
And I kind of
felt guilty asking.
And she said, "You know what?
Let me think about it.
I'll try.
I'll let you know.
When you're in Korea,
I'll send you some voice notes."
So I waited every day,
and I checked my phone,
and I got nothing
from Kelly Clarkson,
and I'm like, "Oh, God,
she's way too busy.
I should've never asked."
I got home from it, and I said,
"I'm gonna unhook her
and tell her
don't worry about it."
She was our first guest
on the show when I came back,
and I looked at her,
and I thought,
"She probably feels awkward,
and she goes, "I did it."
I said, "You did it?"
She said, "I sang the words.
I hope you like it."
We sat down in the studio,
and she played it.
And, Seth, I wept.
One, because there's
no one like Kelly.
And, two, just because
she went to all that trouble.
And, by the way,
I have to tell you something.
I don't know if there's anyone
Kelly Clarkson loves more,
short of her family, than you.
-That is --
-And I'm not kidding!
No, Kelly Clarkson
is so wild about you.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Can I tell you something?
-What?
-I feel the same about her,
and forget about my family.
Because she's --
[ Laughter ]
-She literally finished
this song and said,
"Hoda, I gotta go.
I'm on 'Seth' tonight.
We were day drinking last time,
and I don't know
what we're gonna do."
-Yeah.
-She's literally so crazy
about you, and I love that.
-She's the greatest person
on Earth, and she should
do everything, and everybody
should embrace her at all times.
[ Laughter ]
I would be remiss
if I didn't ask.
How much Korean did you pick up
on your trip?
-That's really
none of your business.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I can't remember any of it.
-Can you even remember hello?
-No. God, I can't believe
you're asking me this.
'Cause I --
-Goodbye? What about --
-Give me a --
Do you remember any of it?
-Do you know any of it?
-I didn't get to go.
Nobody invited me to Korea.
-I can't --
You know what's funny?
I'm one of those people that --
It's like with anything.
I learn it.
I know it at the time.
And then, a week later,
it's gone-zo.
-By the way, if all you knew
was hello and goodbye,
it's not like that's
that impressive, anyway.
Although it's more impressive
than what I'm getting now.
[ Laughter ]
-I cannot remember.
-That's all right.
You have a lot on your plate.
You had to write this book.
-Yeah, you're right.
All 100 words.
-So, anyways, thank you
so much for being here.
Apologies to our Korean audience
that tuned in
to hear Hoda
say hello and goodbye.
-Oh, my God! Stop!
[ Laughter ]
It's always so great to see you.
-Seth, I love you.
-I love you, too.
Congrats on everything.